at the beginning of 2021 people were
generally investing in companies gaining
share because of the pandemic
these were digital companies like amazon
and apple companies we rely on while
we're stuck at home
in the hedge fund community there are so
called long short hedge funds so they
manage their risk
by investing in companies they believe
in but then
to manage their risk they had to be
short something and so they were short
the brick and mortar retailers where
obviously
the coronavirus was impacting their
business but then
individual investors or as wall street
calls them retail traders
decided to get involved by investing in
a heavily shorted company
gamestop gamestop is really the stock
that started sort of all of the mayhem
in the stock market
it was one of the most heavily shorted
stocks on wall street which just meant
that a lot of these hedge fund types had
been looking at the company for years
and didn't think a turnaround was in
store
but what happened with reddit traders to
amass this sort of
huge online discussion board with
millions of followers
is that they were looking at an activist
investor who said he was going to come
into the company
and sort of infuse it with technology
and help it miss a turnaround essential
individual trading has become a lot
easier in recent years with commission
free apps like robinhood
which allow users to buy and sell stock
instantaneously on their phones
these amateur investors continued to use
social media to talk
and continued to buy stocks so much that
prices went up 800 percent in one week
as that started to happen a lot of these
wall street hedge funds that were
betting against the company
they started to get i guess a little
antsy about that some of them had to
start selling their short positions
which
essentially just means that they are
buying back borrowed shares
but they are buying back borrowed shares
that they borrowed at these very very
low game stop prices
and they're now selling them at these
astronomical reddit prices so
they started losing a ton of money and
as reddit traders saw that happening
they started to double down on their
buying and it just
kind of blew up from there the stock
ended january up
sixteen hundred percent which compared
to the s p
500 which is a basket of these 500 large
companies
it was roughly flat so that just kind of
pains the picture of how crazy it was
they started talking about buying other
shortage stocks like amc
blackberry american airlines and
build-a-bear even elon musk tweeted at
one point
game stocks and the price of gamestop
shot up
just more evidence of how crazy it is
that something so small like a tweet can
have a massive effect on prices
retail investors began to realize just
how powerful they can be
according to market participants that
i've spoken to
the losses are enormous somewhere in the
range of 10 to 20 billion dollars
hedge funds they're controlled by some
of the richest people on the planet
and for the longest time now they've had
a lot of influence over
the companies that you know they'll
invest in which
the more they buy up shares the more
prices typically go up because of the
outsized demand
and they haven't really had sort of a
counterparty
in terms of the ordinary investor who
can come in
and sort of exert the same type of
influence people who are looking at the
situation and
there's this impulse called fomo and
you've heard of fear of
missing out that means you go and you do
something because it's working out for
everybody else
i don't want to get left behind i want
to make some money and gain stop
so just be aware that if you buy
gamestop at prices
you know in the 200 100 400
range you're not really um buying into a
company that's
quote unquote worth that much gamestop
is way overvalued so as long as this
mania
persists you'll be fine but manias don't
persist they they end at some point
the effects of the short squeeze were
felt across the market and hedge funds
bore the brunt of the loss
as these hedge funds have begun to
unwind to cover their losses
they've been selling their winners in
their portfolio
and you've seen a lot of very high
quality companies
sell off and it it it appears like the
factor there is that
people in the hedge fund community are
lowering their portfolios and selling
wherever they can and that's actually
spilled over into
high quality companies that really have
nothing to do with this
in terms of the hedge fund community i
think that it may
push investors to
even more sort of tightly managed
risk portfolios and so for some of these
hedge funds that may have done
extremely poorly through this whole
event their risk may have been on the
higher side
and so i think that people may sort of
tighten up the risk and so that would
probably kind of lower the sort of
returns for the hedge fund community
because they're operating with a little
bit more capped risk
this brings up a lot of questions about
trading regulations and whether or not
the reddit traders colluded or
manipulated
the market and some remain angry that
while hedge funds can regularly exercise
large trades without much of a problem
these small traders were stopped when
they tried to get involved
if hedge funds and other wall street
institutional types have been engaging
in similar behavior to what the people
at reddit are accused of
why would you enforce some rules that
didn't apply to
the guys on wall street and then the
hedge funds before to the reddit guys
is it really a bad thing or is it just
what
happens in the market if you're in the
message board saying yes the stock
has you know five dollars per share in
cash on the books and trades at 350.
i think it's a safe bet is that really
fraudulent
pumping of a stock not at all that's
like a good fundamental analysis of it
this dramatic short squeeze could have
u.s lawmakers scrambling to stop
future market volatility in terms of
market manipulation that's maybe
the most interesting and the the hardest
one to put a finger on
because this is all done on kind of a
social media forum
and so it's hard to really point the
finger
at manipulation and unknowing
recklessness that's kind of toes across
the law
right now it's definitely a lot of these
online brokerages like robin hood
and charles schwab and others who have
restricted trading that are getting the
brunt of
the negativity the backlash i would say
because they did you know
barred retail investors from being able
to trade and after
they had like a noticeable influence on
prices which is something that hedge
funds have been able to do for a very
very long time influencing the market
like that without much of a restriction
so
i think there is a huge conversation
around whether the market is essentially
out to get the little guy
and that's something that again the
regulators are going to be looking at
it's not incredibly unprecedented in
terms of the
outsized demand that's causing the price
spikes but again just the fact that this
is a swath of people who are trading
every day
realizing they can have this type of
influence on the stock market that is
pretty unprecedented
you